kids love to see other kids thoroughly
beat up adults i mean it's it's nice to
see the kids win instead of the adults
you know you know
winning all the time the kids win for
once yeah that's when the other kids
like to see that yeah yeah the other
kids like to see
us when instead of the adults
[Music]
well they're faced with three kidnappers
who come at them and they're kind of
easy to beat but really stupid kids yeah
this is like their first major test of
their skill
another big challenge is um rushmore
yeah the big bodyguard
rocky coat remember the practice dummy
light up the eyes boys light up the eyes
let's light this dude up
in the sort of the beginning of the
movie it's like a montage of our
training we hit this practice dummy and
if we hit it in the right places its
eyes will light up
and then we had to remember what we did
with that and hit him and hit this big
guy who was practically invincible in
the same places
[Music]
and we're doing all our own fight scenes
it's the last thing we're not doing are
the flips yeah we don't know gymnastics
but all the fights and kicking and
punching yeah that's all us we're doing
all our own fight scenes and i think
it's cool just being able to do your own
fights and
not to have the stunt doubles doing oh
yeah
it's a lot of fun a lot we all live for
the fight scenes i mean we liked acting
too but when it comes to fight scenes
we're all happy
i like it because you always get to win
you always get to beat up the bad guys
yeah it's a different kind of action
this is like
this is comedy action and you know it's
fantasy there's always a chance of
getting hurt but usually it's very safe
[Music]
it gives you like physical endurance and
it also it's nice to have control over
your body but it also puts that mental
aspect into view you know you get
discipline and concentration it's good
for physical self-defense but it's also
good for concentration it helps
it helps you mature it really brings up
your self-esteem
[Music]
come on boy round two
it's kind of weird seeing i mean i've
said this before we're seeing your face
all over town you know on billboards and
buses yeah
it's kind of neat with the movie opening
out today it's kind of neat yeah it's
really exciting for us one two three
[Music]